[Music]
with more and more international
collaborations and multinational staff
members working on anime coming about we
may get to the point where this debate
as war councils and Hanna made one
doesn't become moot
that is the most melancholy pasta I
brought you a big toddler
[Music]
you have to go back to this five extra
choice.we
is that me broken right now can we is is
this gonna get patched out ah yes the
temperatures coming down the leaves are
starting to turn red and you still
didn't find your summer love which can
mean only one thing the new season of
anime is just about to start where you
can forget all your sorrows with some
cute anime girls or guys we don't judge
here in our community we are all
believers of equality in degeneracy now
as your friendly neighborhood anime
watcher it's my job to go through all
the anime this new season so you don't
have to and who knows maybe we'll both
find a gem we can get excited about
follow religiously then watch as it
slowly disappoints us and drops all the
hype you held at the beginning let's
start off with everyone's favorite
cooking show now I know what you're
thinking what spicy new dishes are they
gonna give us this season cuz you know
that's the best part of the show see how
they're able to handle their fresh meat
into new interesting dishes and nothing
else
speaking of sequels I'll definitely be
watching cake I Simpson has picked up
exactly where it left off and holy [ __ ]
if I had a boner before this scene has
definitely finished it off thank you
again I'm glad to see that it's still
full of character and as stylish as ever
so yeah not much do I have you already
seen the first season except God I
missed the old ending know that new ones
are bad but can we just agree that this
was one of the best V's in recent memory
you know normally I wouldn't give a show
like this a second look but thanks to
made an abyss I'm now obligated to check
out every show about chibi explorers on
the off chance that they'll turn out
amazing
it was a must Eric it was Q and the
world seems interesting so you know what
um I actually give this one a [ __ ] wait
hold on a second did did they just
you
saying the show is all for giving it a
chance was a massive mistake hey I hear
the most annoying sound in the world
[Music]
so black cloud was hyped up as being one
of the possible new big shonan's of this
generation and so far it's been an
absolute mess not even counting the main
characters [ __ ] constant it's as
generic as Shona can be right now and it
feels like the show is ten years old and
has much more in common with titles in
the year of the big three rather than
how the genre has slowly evolved in
recent times at the moment it's just a
very poor man's Naruto who an equally
wealthy man's fairy tale a moment of
silence please for the comments section
in the same way that my hero academia
shows us how we can take every generic
Shonen trope and refine it to a tee blaq
clover has shown us how we can take
every generic Shonen trope and make it
completely generic the main character is
annoying as hell we were given the
[ __ ] flashback in episode two nothing
about this show is special so far and
you know the part that pisses me off the
most I'm still probably gonna watch
anyway click on shown in trash so any
Aashiqui marks the second manga on my
recommended manga video to be adapted by
mapper but some was honestly a bit
disappointed in this first episode the
pacing was lightning fast that we
weren't given enough time to actually
care about these characters or let the
consequences of any actions sink in it
feels like this should have been two
episodes worth of material but it is
just the first episode after all and
every seasonal anime has to start off
with a bang so I still have high hopes
for this if anything I can thank you for
letting man with the mission complete
their Holy Trinity of Hyper's Balls
one-liner anime openings
[Music]
I feel like after Eromanga sensei I've
been given kind of a bad rep when it
comes to little sisters in anime for
some reason I really can't tell as a lot
of you've been telling me to watch this
new emo so anime but I mean after
Eromanga sensei I really don't know what
new things can be done vivica kept on
totally - you know - I see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wait a minute this is just the first two
minutes of the episode oh I I say it's
it's it's the good old incest
bait-and-switch
Fiona's the oldest trick in the book
it's about a light novel author obsessed
with writing light novels about little
sisters so I assume this is the memoirs
of the era manga sensei author because I
can definitely see where the inspiration
comes from so many comics kita sky it's
been 14 years since the last quino's
journey so I'm guessing a bunch of you
knew what anime fans will have never
heard of it so I'm just gonna pull out
my old [ __ ] card and say watch this first
episode it's an episodic show so you
don't need to watch the original all he
needs knows that it's about a girl
traveling to different countries each
with different rules and laws that
explore interesting philosophies and
mentalities the first episode looks at
what could possibly happen if there was
a country where the act of murder was
legal the original anime was great and
this one's looking like you'll be good
to wait a minute this is mega mah Weiss
is Maggie mah is this new niggy ma how
ever heard of this before
[Music]
back in the day when I was just but a
teenager I was enamored by the works of
Kenna Komatsu the harem God at the time
and his works like Love Hina and nagamma
still hold a close place in my heart as
they helped shape me to the man I am
today I regret nothing
the negev a manga though ended up
turning into an awesome Shonen battle
series so excuse me while I squeal in
nostalgia because they use the original
Opie and there's Meggie and there's all
the girls and Abel's gone full kiss
shorter what what everybody help you
hands well test you up so we have a
tournament where twelve super-powered
combatants fight to the death and the
winner gets their wish granted isn't
this just fate isn't this just fate with
edge isn't this just fate with a lots of
[ __ ] edge I mean it looks fun as hell
and the fight choreographies great but
let's be real here this is just edge
stay Knight and held that isn't even
clearly the edgiest show of the season
because we've got a group of
super-powered Nazis led by charismatic
leader tried to bring down the world's
destruction that's right it's a car Mego
Hitler the brakes don't stop on this
edge train though because next we've got
evil or live that's right in this cruel
world when you're given two choices you
can either live or you either
and finally if there just wasn't enough
edge this season we have Kings game
where you have a show with all the
ingredients to bake that perfect edge
cake see what you want to do is start
off with your standard death game base
sprinkle in some exploding bodies mix in
some suicide with just a dash of rain
now put it in the oven and let it sit
for about season and voila you've just
baked yourself a nice new [ __ ] boy who
gave me the mirai nikki ingredients list
so there's an anime called just because
why i'm just just just [ __ ] because
okay but after the first episode i have
no idea what the show is actually about
so let's just read the synopsis at the
end of the second semester of 3rd year
of high school for students are prepared
for graduation and feel the ending to
their high school life well that changes
a little with the arrival of a transfer
students okay
i still have no idea what the show is
actually about all right governor
we london now 5 million pounds is this
how much the pounds going down after
break sir coco Alain Delon is she in
grande a la Hache con la única wait a
minute I've lived in London this ain't
[ __ ] West London unless is this the
legendary zone 6 I've heard so much
about way of those yeah they are what
are they doing in London bloody
immigrants all right so this is looking
like the newest Hotte show of the season
and I can wholly see why it has the same
vibe and appeal or something like Harry
Potter with a world of mystique mages
and magic that you want to explore and
learn more of without being in any way a
ripoff so far there hasn't really been a
hook in the plot or with anything going
on but the atmosphere and setting have
certainly intrigued me as I just want to
see more of this world so yeah with all
things considered the season is looking
up we got some great sequels some good
originals and the mix of fun one so yeah
that's for 2017 there's nothing else
literally that's left to talk about at
all please don't make me do it
[Music]
what is this is this visual cancer or
just outright terrorism I don't think
this counts as a terror attack because
Isis haven't claimed responsibility for
this yet maybe this is just Japan's
declaration of war against humanity this
can get a second seasoned and this is it
this is the final proof we need to
confirm that we are on the darkest
timeline there is only one path that
awaits us now
[Music]
[Music]
this is airing on anime strike crisis
averted
if you want to avoid the dark your moto
dystopia at all cost then you can do so
by putting them where they belong in the
[ __ ] trash that's why you can get
your exclusive saggy trash and amaru
dumps the pins from otaku pin club links
are in the description below more
details coming up hey guys hope you
enjoyed the video I like to give a shout
out to otaku pin club in this video as
you can guess from their name they make
anime pin so yeah they approached me and
asked if I had any ideas for any designs
so of course I came up with the trash
tiger II and dumpster Amaru pins if you
want either of those one of the kind
pins then three orders are in the
description below or come out sometime
next month
as you can see they do a high-quality
metal pin so yeah I'm really looking
forward to seeing how those pins turn
out and also I'd like to thank Jerrica
tell Vincent Mooney Lau can gigaku I'm
now just going to rename patreon giga to
avoid confusion and everyone else a
patreon for so helping to support me and
making this video possible anyway not
any more updates from me I will be in
Japan again next week so for Weibo
so yeah that's it from me I've been gig
I can I will see you all next time